to me you know it's just always very
specifically about the character you
know themselves this is kind of you know
he's actually sort of one of the
original hard-boiled detectives it's
always attractive when there's somebody
who you've worked with before you know
you work with well
but it's also very exciting to work with
new people and also first timers is is
really lovely but I think most
importantly you just try to throw it
away try to forget it is it true
he wants to listen to the confession
with nothing more than piercing look
with enough patience a suspect will
offer
interrogate himself Christian they all
kind of aged perfectly into the
protagonist it's our third film together
and uh and I've been a long time admire
of Edgar Allan Poe so it's really kind
of a dream come true to be able to
direct my closest friend and tell a
story about a writer that I've long
admired what type of fella could do this
when you have to play someone as well
known as iconic because as Edgar Allan
Poe is
I guess there's certain things that you
kind of that could be daunting I guess
it was a combination of doing lots of
research and then having fun and seeing
what worked and what didn't work uh I do
want to be restricted by that research I
wanted it to try and open up a sense of
play and fun because I really hope the
audience would enjoy this character when
the environment is kind of
isolated from the rest of the world
especially because we were in quarantine
while doing this and I think it really
lent itself to that sense of kind of
Disconnect from the rest of the world
that this story really requires as well
there's something very claustrophobic
and dark about it we are closer
[Music]
[Applause]
it's only a matter of time